Hi!
I'm Anna Akana.
And I'm here to help women everywhere
not get raped.
Because it's totally our responsibility, right?
(dramatic chord)
The best form of rape prevention
is to assimilate yourself into society as a man.
Now I know what you're thinking.
"Anna, rape does NOT just apply to women."
This is true.
So to ensure the safety of your butt,
spread a rumor that you yourself are a rapist,
so other rapists
will see you as a colleague.
Anna: Hey fellas!
Anna: How dem rapes looking lately?
Guys: What?
Anna: Yeah, you get any good rapes, dawg?
Guy 1: Yeah, we're busy right now.
Guy 2: Yeah.
Anna: Busy thinking 'bout dat rape~
Guy 1: Okay, we're gonna get--
Anna: Hey guys, come on bruh!
Anna: Give me some rape tips, dawg!
Anna: I just wanna learn how to rape from you!
Anna: Yo, we're friends, dawg!
(Arguing) Anna: Wait here! Get back, I wanna rape!
Man: NO! NO!
If you absolutely cannot pretend to be a man
façading as a rapist,
another expensive and fear-induced solution
is to hire bodyguards.
Will you protect me from rape?
Yes ma'am.
We will.
But will you rape me?
Yes ma'am.
We will.
I'm just gonna...
call 911 really quick.
If your bodyguards aren't trustworthy,
protect yourself the old American way.
(dingdong)
Excuse me, do you have the time?
(whoosh)
(gunshots)
No I don't have the time.
For rape.
(gunshot)
We've been conditioned our whole lives
to not get raped.
My dad put me in martial arts.
My mom gives me knives and pepper spray,
and despite the fact that I like that stuff,
it's mostly for anti-rape.
We're told by society,
"Never walk alone at night.
Never walk down an alleyway.
If you think you're being followed, make 3 right turns
cause that means they just went in a circle.
Never run upstairs if you're being chased
cause then you can get trapped.
Don't stop if you see a car seat on the side of the road.
Hey, here's some nail polish that'll
help you identify date-rape drugs.
Support this adorable yet fierce keychain
so you can gouge someone's eyes out."
And on,
and on,
and on.
You know what would be better?
If we just taught young boys
that rape isn't even an option.
If we would stop victim-shaming and slut-shaming,
and excusing a rapist
because of the clothes his victim wore,
or because they were on a date.
Cause I am seriously
so fucking tired
of being responsible
for not getting raped.
I'm Anna Akana.
You stay awesome.
(ending music)
Subtitles by Skylar Coland via Amara